You know, it's good too, is the rap. You
know, some guys going to fight, you know,
like rapping. Well, no, it's,
I used to beat guys like you
up on the way to a fight.
Practice fall on asshole. You
know that shit. I like that.
Just like in basketball, you know that
the, the uh, trash talk, trash and toxic.
Yeah. Sometimes it works. Does the thing
about when someone gets inside your head,
someone's really lucky that I was kind
of thinking that when you see listing and
I'll, right, yeah. How could,
like it looked like listen, was
like afraid of him. How could he be?
Well, you know, you go back, the reason
why, and this is, Ali did this on purpose.
He acted like a crazy person because he's
like that Sonny Liston was a bully and
Sonny Liston was a big scary man.
And what he felt like sunny lists it
would be afraid of is a crazy person.
Someone who was afraid of him.
So in all the press conferences and all
the different things leading up to the
fight, he would scream at them.
He would show up at Sonny Liston,
his house and honked the
horn in the middle of the
night and get on his lawn and
scream and yell at him.
Like he did a lot of crazy shit to sunny,
listened to fuck with them psychologically
he wanted Sonny and he did it.
He did it psychologically.
They didn't want it.
Sonny Liston to think that he was
a crazy person and that you know,
that he would never
stop. Yeah. And that's,
I mean he essentially did it and there
was one point in time when they were, um,
see we just let me hear some of this.
He,
he laid him down.
He let him know he wasn't scared of him
and they were doing his blood pressure
and his blood pressure was so high.
As heart rate was so high,
they weren't going to let them find
them like doing sunny. Oh No. Ali's,
he had a calm himself down cause he
got himself worked up into a lather.
He was just so, so angry and so, you know,
so hyped up trying to
act like a crazy person.
Then when they were doing it's pre-fight
medicals, they were like, hey, you know,
like you can't fight your fucking,
there's something wrong with you.
And they had this, here it
is. They're calming him down.
He had to relax and calm down. I don't
know. Greatest, greatest of all time.
I beat him all.
He was just so,
so smart at like psychological warfare.
There'd never been any anybody like
him psychologically that could just,
he would, he, first of
all, he was very funny.
He would say hilarious shit.
Like Howard Cosell said to him,
tramp it champion seem very trucky
let, and he goes, whatever on it is,
if it's good on that,
the timing was just perfect.
He was so, he would, you know,
say things that were funny.
He would say poetry.
He had that Guy Bundini Brown behind
him and they were always, you know,
there were always like laughing
and joking around together.
Like he had a tremendous support team
and on top of that he could fight his
fucking ass off. And he was a heavyweight
that moved around like a middleweight.
Unbelievable. I mean, he
was a 200 plus pound, 215,
220 pound man.
And he would shuffle and move and Bob and
weave and he would be out there almost
like a welter winning. He's
the greatest. He's a boy.
It's hard to say who's the
greatest heavyweight of all time,
but he's certainly in the conversation.
I mean, you would have to say,
how would he have done
against some of the bigger,
stronger guys of the past? Like
a Lennox Lewis who, uh, you know,
was in his prime in the
high 240 pound range.
She was a much bigger, much bigger
guy, but there was nobody left.
See,
Ali also comes in two stages.
There's Ali before 1967 when they took
his license away. And this is Ali.
After 1970 when he came back and when
he came back, he was never as fast.
He was never as fleet of foot cause he
didn't work out at all for three years.
He didn't do shit now. And when
he came back, his return fight,
um, uh, he just didn't look right.
He didn't look like he
had the same movement.
His body didn't have the same
musculature. He just, uh, he fought. Um,
Jerry, no, it wasn't very
core. Jerry quarry, that's
what it was. And he beat him.
He beat him up,
but he just didn't look like then the
homily that fought like go to boxing
matches. Yeah. Yeah. I'll
still go to boxing matches.